I wanna compliment you.
I don't, I've known you for a long time
and we've worked together a little bit
and I've always thought
you were hilarious.
And I watched your Netflix film last night
and I started to watch it by myself
and this movie starts from the get-go,
the firing guns starts, you
show up, I think 30 seconds
into the film.
And I was laughing so
hard that I paused it
and I went and found my wife and I said,
"You have to watch this with me, honey."
And so we went back to
the start of the movie
and you just kill it.
You are so funny in this movie
and I'm so happy for you
because I really do think this
is one of those performances
that's going to change everything for you
and I'm really happy.
Ah, thank you so much, that's so nice.
Yeah, and I think coming from me (laughs)
we all know the power, Lauren
that I wheeled in the business.
This is huge for me, yeah. (laughs)
I'm like Spielberg in '87,
(laughs)
it's the equivalent 'cause that's the,
oh, this changes everything
but no, it was so funny
and you were so funny
in so many different ways
and I was remembering that
the first time I saw you
was in a little improv show for
kids called "Story Pirates."
Yes, yeah, we got to do that together.
I mean, you didn't get to do it with me
but I got to do it with you
and it was very exciting.
It's this theater company
in New York and LA
that takes stories written by children
and adapts them into
the sketches and songs
and it's really fun
and really high quality
kids entertainment.
And I used to be in that
theater company in New York
and LA and we did a show at the Geffen
and we had you as our celebrity
guest and it was so fun.
I think you sang a song about
wetting your pants which--
Sounds like me.
(laughs)
That's an old Gershwin classic by the way.
"The Wrong Missy," I think,
is one of the most
popular films on Netflix.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. (laughs)
Huge, I mean, it's, this
is a big deal for you
and this is through Adam
Sandler's production company,
this film and Adam Sandler's
the executive producer
and Adam's wife is in the film
and then I notice and she does a great job
but then I notice there's this really,
there's this moment where your character
loses it, can be incredibly foul-mouthed,
can be incredibly foul in
all these different ways,
it's hilarious.
But there's this moment where
you're yelling at these kids
when you show up at this resort in Hawaii
and I notice that the
kids are Adam's kids.
Yeah.
And you're being really,
and I'm like, "Was Adam on
set when that happened?"
He was there that day and it was kind of,
it was interesting 'cause I
think for a little bit I felt
more pressure because
he was there, of course
and I like him, I admire him
and I'm like, "Oh I have to
perform all in front of him
but I then I also have
to scream at his kids"
and he just told me to go harder.
He was like, "Just scream,
just swear at them,
just go, like just come in hot."
And I was like, "Okay."
And they liked it, they
were great but. (laughs)
Oh, no I'm sure they got it
but do you sense in a weird
way that Adam was using you
to vent anger at his kids?
(laughs) Yeah, that was really
clear, actually. (laughs)
And that maybe possibly
that was the reason the
whole movie existed. (laughs)
(laughs) Just to have
that one scene. (laughs)
There's a part in the movie
where you get fish chum,
just chunks of fish parts
thrown in your face and
it looks really disgusting
and they sell it really well
and I thought what, I'm just
hoping that that was plastic
and fake and not real.
I have to tell you it was 100% real
because (laughs), well actually
it was supposed to be fake
but then the prop guy
told me the day before,
he pulled aside and he was like,
"Hey, that fish I was
supposed to get this fake fish
and it didn't arrive in time
and so I'm gonna use real fish."
And I was like, "Ha-ha, yeah,
yeah, cool, that's funny."
And he was like, "No, I'm dipping it lemon
and I'm trying to make it smell good
and I'm taking all the bones
out but it's gonna be real."
And I was like, "Okay,"
it's just like I feel like
I can't argue against that,
I just have to go with that. (laughs)
And so then they're
just dumping fish in my,
Rob Schneider and stuntman
are just throwing actual
fish guts in my face and hair
and then people have to debone
me for an hour on the boat.
Then we do it again.
(laughs)
Okay, I'm gonna say this on your behalf,
that doesn't happen to you again.
(laughs)
I understand that you had
to do this to end this movie
but I think after this movie, that's done.
Maybe now I can stand up for myself
and just (laughs) I don't know.
I don't know what you're supposed to do
in that situation, though,
I mean, just say to make it all CGI
or something, I don't know.
I'll tell you that I've been
having doing the show for
whatever 27 years or something
and I've gotten to the point
where I'll bitch about it
and be passive-aggressive.
Yeah.
They're like, "Okay, well
we just won't do it."
And I'll go like, "No, no, it's fine."
And then I put on a woman's
thong and they drop me
into liquid diarrhea.
I think I missed that episode. (laughs)
That's a good episode.
(laughs)
It was, man, it was a
theme episode, it was--
Okay, your personal perversions.
Okay, was that my, oh that's,
yeah, that's my perversion, yeah.
(laughs)